hey what's up guys my name is a China
welcome to episode 33 of 3d game
programming in Java okay so it's been a
while since last since the last episode
and I apologize for that but I had um I
had a lot of work to do for school I had
to folios to you last week and yeah you
know had fun doing that now this one um
took a lot of time so I yeah I apologize
for that but here we are with episode 33
alright so a few things I wanted to do
for this episode
um and 2 things that people have been
really asking me the first thing the
people seem to be asking me is not the
first thing I want to do actually
actually before I do anything else
actually I just wanted to point out real
quick that um I've been actually getting
into PC gaming a lot more recently you
know in my free time which is like
literally about two hours a week I've
been I've been getting into PC gaming
again so what I did is I thought I
thought it would be cool to make a steam
group called Cherno and no one even took
the name sure no which was surprising
which was awesome so I grabbed that and
I made a group um last night and yeah
basically what you guys can do is if
you've got steam you can go ahead and on
the URL is it'll be the first link in
the description it's steam community.com
for such groups for such the channel and
what you can do is you can join that
steam group it's public anyone can join
and what you can do from then on is I'll
try and play with you guys at some point
because I can see when you're online you
can see when I'm online and basically if
you can see that I'm online playing
something like Team Fortress 2 which I
probably won't be doing because I'm not
a big fan of that game but anyway point
is if you see me playing ah if you see
me playing like man warfare 2 or
something online then you can just join
into my session in progress as simple as
that so it's kind of like we're friends
but we're not actually friends like if
you don't I mean it's not like I'm
adding you as a contact on front on
Steam it's more like um you know you can
just like this guy Smitty like he's
playing killing floor ok I can't join
that intro to rest actually a problem
maybe I can if I go into steam um I
can't
but you know I can um
send my message I can basically talk to
them I can make group chat and stuff
like that and you can also do events
which is really cool so I could do an
event where you know all of us play Team
Fortress 2 or something together in a
server or something like something like
that I'm not sure I'm saying um that
this is something that I think is pretty
cool so if you do have seen go ahead and
join the steam group the description the
link is in the first like line of the
description anyway let's get back to let
me just close steams and no one like I
tries to talk to me um okay sure
ah two things I want to do um a lot of
people have been asking me you know how
do I make this ceiling a different
texture right so the ceiling at the
moment is the same texture to the floor
and in if you actually look at the code
there's no real way to UM if we jump the
code then you'll see that oh here we go
when we're setting no that's not that if
we're setting the thing you know there's
what only setting like the texture once
so there's no actual you know way to say
okay let's make the floor this texture
it's not like the sprites basically or
the walls where we felt like separate
separate I guess declarations and
assignments for those separate things
here we don't all right here we've just
got at once so how do we change the roof
the ceiling how do we change how do we
differentiate between those two textures
we'll do that today as well as the other
thing that I really want to do let me
just empty my recycle bin because I'd
like to have an empty the other thing
that I wanted to do was uh to UM
basically make these high resolution
because I mean at the moment they're
like eight by eight or something that's
like ah I don't know that's just spits a
bit small you guys I'm sure we don't
want to say each individual pixel here
I'm not sure like I personally probably
would have left like this like that's
fine this is this looks fine I reckon
but um just in case you guys do want to
do some high resolution stuff I will do
that today so first thing I want to do
real quick is I've got if you open up
your directory of your game then you
know that in the resources folder we've
got a textures folder and
basically flawed PNG are our three
textures now what we're going to do
today is we actually basically make them
high-resolution all right so it's
actually harder than looks or than it
sounds actually I just get to paint on
that real quick and I'll just open I
keep having to remember that I've only
got one screen like when I'm because
I've got two screens I've got dual
monitors but when I'm recording
obviously I'm only recording one screen
so I have to make sure that everything I
do is on this screen so yeah okay so
back to here um basically let's just go
I don't even want to um let's just I'll
screw that let's just make a new thing
maybe not that revolution but uh let's
make a new new-money collar paint.net
file I don't know a new picture base a
new image and I don't know what size
reckon we should have let's just make a
double the resolution that it currently
is that'll be enough you guys can
increase the resolution further than
that if you really want
in fact double double double what are
times four so at the moment got a could
make it 32 by 32 pixels yeah let's make
it 32 by 32 so 32 times 3 is 96 so
because we've got three textures
actually will make for textures weren't
we
so 96 plus 32 is what 128 okay thanks
let me just make sure that is 128 yes it
is um because we want one for the roof
once the ceiling as well and the height
32 so alright if we just come into here
then we can see that at the bottom
that's 32 pixels now that's 33 there we
go 32 by 32 and it even tells you like
the area that it's 1,024 pixels squared
that's pretty cool anyway so I guess I'm
just gonna look on our old image here
just right this is really hard
one monitor damn I disliked it ah 32 by
32 just so I'm just looking down here to
say what it is alright and we're just
trying to map trying to match that
roughly so let's just grab a what was it
it was basically like a that's right um
like a doc right and more or less like a
pie right maybe like that that looks
nice
and we'll grab the gradient tool and
just you can see how much high
resolution that looks by the way yeah
that's the difference
that'll be right ah what was the other
way around so I get a bit I got a bit
lighter because I don't think that
there's enough difference there we go
that's nice alright um we're gonna
remove this yeah there we go
okay so um I'll just grab the we had
like a white outline as well so let's do
that so that whoops just like both them
okay that didn't work
um okay so we're making this white cool
okay so our next step that is let me
just make sure that is that's too high
res for me there we go
so that should be 32 by 32 again and the
ceiling texture let's uh what should we
make for this ceiling
um hmm let's just make it like a
different color gradient maybe like a
greenish where a veneers growing that
much well that look like yeah it's not
bad the green color sucks doesn't it
there we go darker colors just look
better than lighter colors I think it's
just the feeling I get like okay ah we
should probably switch them around
actually so that can be like to see Liam
that can be like the grass on the floor
or something yeah well do that alright
so this will be the floor tech so
that'll be the ceiling texture
just save this as out blocks so this
will be like out the textures for our
blocks basically as a PNG well okay
next up on our list is this target type
thing so that's a sprite um I don't know
the world textures next so that's just
like a blue I don't know will change the
wall textures like actually let's just I
don't even know like I I don't know I
can't I can't be creative when I'm
recording tutorials so I can't think of
anything but if you bear with me then
I'll try walls what are we have no walls
what if what if we add like a painting
or something you guys don't know how to
set different textures to different
walls I don't want to get into too many
textures now just because I want to save
that for actual level design when we do
that which will probably be maybe next
episode because on the next like episode
or whatever the next few episodes anyway
we arm will actually sell them to
creating different different types of
blocks so that we can then you know
place those blocks into the level and
create actual levels but before we do
that I'll just keep it simple I guess
for now so let's just desaturate that a
bit maybe make it a brighter as well ah
damn it
okay that'll be our so Walter sure and
finally the sprite type thing will be um
okay um the sprite thing will be um this
is going to suck so much because yeah
this is tiny now let's zoom in a bit um
uh-huh okay well we still want to retain
our transparency don't we so let's just
yeah like a let's just um
because grain wasn't it let's make it a
bit darker green and then what I'll do
is all just basically do this for the
I'm not going to do the same to auto
type thing I just very is my color that
can I know again it's gonna be the whole
thing just hoping it's like the same
errors as a thing okay doesn't matter um
actually yes it does because we can just
copy and paste I can't worry I'm feeling
shy we can okay copy paste yep
move awesome that worked okay let me
just get out of here colors put that on
my other monitor I paste it a few more
times as well if we how can we rotate in
this program apparently not no well
we'll just have to improvise and do this
mm not sure what I do that's clearly not
square
Oh doesn't matter um doesn't matter okay
it's not even going to be you know what
that will be enough again darker red I
just fill it in alright cool so here are
our high resolution textures which look
amazing
and let's just um I just want like
bugging me always make this it's what
does make it too wide again um and then
we'll just make this like a white for
now but we'll change it into like pink
in a second not buster Oh
hope you guys enjoying this cuz I'm not
oh yeah yeah we can just delete it
actually
okay that's fine actually screw it I'm
done I'm done with this all right let's
just grab the paint bucket and we'll
make the color FF 0 0 FF which is pink
and we'll just fill this whole damn
thing in pink sweet cool oh let's save
that make sure you save that okay so
we've got high resolution textures how
great um let's let's start so first
thing we want to do is basically we want
to do the wall thing sorry there's
ceiling we want to have a different
texture for the ceiling don't we so to
do that we got to think that the ceiling
we define the ceiling over here right
when we go onto here we've got a ceiling
and it's here you know if if ceiling is
less than zero this is this yummy this
is where we reverse the movement right
if we didn't reverse the movement then
you know that the ceiling goes in the
same Oh actually it doesn't even work
but um ah this is where the ceiling gets
I guess cost this is what the ceiling
gets created so what we need to do
basically is the way I would do it is
I'd make a variable called C for ceiling
I don't know I said that equal to 0 and
turn it and all I do is um I said I'd
set it equal to like when I'm when I'm
doing the floor so just like the floor
I'd set C equal to zero and when we're
doing the ceiling when it's you know
because it's this whole thing is in a
loop right floor is being rerouted
constantly so when we're doing ceiling
it let's set C equal to one so then in
the textures what we can say is keep
losing it here it is um we can say that
if C is equal to zero then God then um
I'll render that else you know do
basically the opposite so let's just
test that our first thing is you'll see
that we are well okay we'll work it
definitely worked because you can see
I'm see that we're getting different
textures here but more importantly if we
just paste that into here one more time
and then we can maybe add like I don't
know what we've got there
we've I love this one okay we've got a
blue wall texture so that's what let's
add a cross so if we just add eight to
this then you can essentially see that
we've we've replaced the the yeah okay
nothing to explain here we've replaced
we've we've made a ceiling inside
texture so with that in mind that's how
you make the ceiling a different texture
obviously we can obviously do the same
thing for thin you know if we want to be
surprised to be that works as simple as
that for one of the thing to be
transparent then you know we'd have to
do the same thing as we did here I'm
going to show you guys how to do that um
what do we do it runs right there okay
what do the same way you do the same way
to get the pink not render okay so now
now that we've got that done let's make
everything high resolution so a bizarre
not give me an hour two plus signs and a
rose I don't know Center sir
doesn't seem yes it is now but if it's
got a space in between it's not
apparently that's what yet I didn't know
that cool okay so high-resolution stuff
um first thing we need to do is our
sprite sheet width has changed it is now
128 wide so when you change that to be
128 now because we've essentially what
are we done
we've multiplied it by two and multiply
two by two again which is multiplying it
by four right so it used to be 24 s be
32 I know it used to be 24
and now it used to be eight for each
texture and now it's become 32 which is
four times eight right so we're
multiplying it by four essentially so
what we need to do is make this thirty
my calculations are correct and um this
by the way what am I in earnest right
so the sprite is how many cross that
it's nine six across isn't it and that's
the sprite the wall is the walls the
blue thing isn't it yep so the wall it's
not much of a color distinction at all
is that oh the wall it's almost a solid
color the wall is um
sixty-four across so that's 64 and make
sure this is 30 and yeah it's going to
take a while to actually adjust ah this
is a sprite and here is the yeah the
thing that we just did so um
replace all leaves us with 30 and oh
yeah it's about it okay so the hmm well
not like wonder if that'll work
let's let's try it out so let's
obviously change the attacher to be
block I'm actually just gonna rename
this to so I tax I don't are because
these are like even like block maybe
because you know there's a it's not too
not just the floor in that one file
let's just test this out because I have
no idea what'll happen okay it crashed
um we're gonna crash because I didn't
didn't find the file what happened to
the file did we don't save the file
odd blocks
whoops my bad all right okay Wow so okay
okay so essentially it's worked right
but essentially okay it it sort of
worked but it sort of hasn't let me just
grab some water first of all we're not
exactly like it's clearly done something
right out our wall to become blue our
sprite to become green what is it done
essentially is it's just made everything
bigger you can see how big the grid
suddenly is now it's not it's not making
it it's not actually making it high
resolution is making it bigger right so
we need to fix that ASAP so if we go
back into render 3d then again remember
when I said that we multiplied it by
four right so they're four times bigger
what we have to do is we have to come in
through our textures so when we actually
set the variable for textures which is
here right X Payson Y pitch what we need
to do is ah basically multiply by four
right and I am white let's put this in
brackets oh hang on this isn't the
textures yes it is all right sweet so
you can see bear how that's worked I
swear I call the textures didn't I oh I
didn't the other thing I did it in walls
this should be called textures really
okay so you can see that by multiplying
that stuff by four so essentially we
just multiplying this stuff by 4 right
was saying actually it probably would be
easier to do it there hmm
now I'll leave it like that but
essentially we're just multiplying this
by four because they're four times
bigger so you can see now that these are
actually high-resolution things and you
can see how many pixels there are you
guys could just go to town on this and
they're currently like 32 by 32 you can
make them 512 by 512 or 1024 by 1024
actually if one of you guys could do
that
and like I don't know tweet me the
picture or the result of it I'd be
actually pretty interested to see that
I'll even work but um the point is we've
made there's a lot higher resolution now
sweet okay so is and we know that's the
whole thing because I put a white border
around it so that white border seems to
be complete which means that it in
worked essentially let's do the same
thing for this so when we're applying
the texture we're saying X extra so we
need to also multiply this by 4 for the
X texture and 4 for this so you can see
now that the sprites are normal size and
when you do the same thing for the wall
so over here we're using X texture and
white Astor again so make sure you just
multiply by 4 you could just make this
32 really actually I'll keep it as 8 and
then times 4 just so that we actually
get to UM to see you know housework
times 4 alright so we can't actually see
a difference with the down wall because
it's a solid color let me go back into
freakin 19 close good go back into here
and quickly not make it a solid color
okay or open recent blocks that's it
so I really that is a salt is that a
solid car you kidding me
how did I make it a solid color I'm
going to just see if there's actually a
difference between the two
no it's a solid color Wow okay so I'm
adding a gradient okay we got this let's
just make a basically darker oh no just
a darker version of it really gradients
and there we go and for testing purposes
what I would also do is just basically
put a border around it like this you
know just so we can um just like a
blackboard or even just so we can see if
it's actually like rendering the entire
thing because you know we if it cuts off
here for example and it only renders say
I know let me just fill us in real quick
and it only renders say you know this
portion when I'm going to be able to
tell that is only rendering like half of
it or three-quarters of it because you
know there's nothing to say that you
know we can't really tell that there's
more in that texture then is being
rented so yeah fill that in and then
we'll just pick like something like
white and um that in life anyway I'll
pick something like a white and um and
we'll just fill in the rest with white
why does it get color it's a nice car
alright save okay all right so we can
see now that we're getting both so in
other ways is working cool
now see if I was really precise with
this and if I was really serious about
this I probably actually go even further
than that and say let's make it 1 pixel
big so paint
nets so what I want to do now is I can't
like on Duke and I know okay this sucks
um let's just make yeah I'll do that I'm
going to pick something one pixel big so
it's three pixels at the moment so this
is one pixel right and I'm going to do
is I want to get like a red still want
to look nice like a gold maybe just a
one pixel big outline around the entire
thing so that I can see really if the
math is perfect too because it needs to
be damn it's annoying why does it do
that
why doesn't it just oh alright so now
I've got a gold thing around the entire
thing
uh-huh that's it this is why I did that
look been cut off it's not working it's
only displaying um well see here here
you can mistake it from for working but
you can see that it's not actually
displaying the high Tatra it's been cut
off so we had to fix that um let's just
add like one now so this is annoying
because it's Tyrell ocean shouldn't be
doing this
oh I was doing that for the bottom as
well actually I think I know why it's
doing it no hang on hang on hold your
horses
alright sure okay um just like on a
crash on us it is 31
when I have to probably say that that's
probably as close as we can get it
without causing major problems and
having to rewrite the entire code for
the whole game you can see that we also
move a lot slower now just because
everything's like bigger so we've
essentially made to play a smaller in a
way all right damn okay
ah let's just add on like no I'm just
watching this as well yeah see that's
right plus one plus one no that's not
right neither is that actually damn okay
Oh
doesn't matter that's pretty close I
mean we're still getting the one pixel
border actually I think is that perfect
because the reason it's doubling up here
is because it's two of it not the same
so does that let's not render the top
four minutes just like and diagnoses
properly we render wall it's rendering
this as well just comment out this
entire section real quick so that we
only rend at the bottom half Oh dead
work all right cool
so you can see that the gold outline is
even across it across you know
everything so sweet all right don't
worry about that clipping because
there's supposed to be a wall down all
right awesome
so that it's probably not going to
conclude today's episode um just
thinking
does one of the thing I wanted to say
maybe yeah I'm not sure
oh hang on rapido up to a ceiling spend
like half the episodes on a side of the
ceiling is supposed to be a different
girl
Oh another the floors by the bridge we
call the full supposably that green
color isn't it so yeah good thing I
didn't in the upset that I'm
embarrassing let's just add on like a 32
on here and we should nope all the way
around apparently okay all right that
looks crap actually dogs last thing I
was saying let's jump into pattern and
again can't leave it like that
no way probably lose help my subscribers
believe in grass looking on that
okay so grass is nice and green I was in
all that green so we'll make a nice
gradient from that too maybe if we just
do this well let's look like all crap
that's um where's a gradient why is
it not get out to understand yeah it's
not dog enough
I should say what this looks like better
than this problem yeah I care that'll be
good enough for now
what if we just make it a solid color
actually what'll that let look crap as
well what we essentially could do and
what I probably would do actually if I
was actually making again um is I
probably just make I don't know how big
this I don't know how big this world is
how big this world is but that's all
that big I probably just make like a
huge texture a huge grass texture for
like the entire thing because it's
obvious it is obviously being you know
tiled I'd probably I love how he's
really high-resolution look how solid
this looks looks brilliant looks amazing
we could probably even real quick just
jump in here and maybe type some text
look at new layer just to make sure that
text is on top oops new layer
what color is the text screen let's make
it black why can't we see this I don't
get why we can't see the damn text damn
okay oh maybe because it was slighted
I'm not sure oh cool all right so say
for China and let's make it a lot bigger
than it currently is oops
no no no yeah there we go
how can i edit this damn text what if i
just not okay this is the 9um 20s wait
and then we'll just delete this damn
thing
there we go all right so let's see what
this looks like
NAR don't save it so it is the thing
that's currently saved as what well it's
as I made a layer doesn't matter let's
just file save as whoops
file save as PNG save yes okay sway to
flatten um let's run this cool so now
we've got to see that's still pretty low
res but hey we probably made this high
resolution if I was really serious about
it but again that is uh that is the
episode this episode 33 of 3d am
programming job I hope you enjoyed it
and don't forget to join the steam group
if you haven't already and well not much
else to say really
I'll try and make a few episodes
throughout the week on different things
just because I might have time might
have time I don't think I like one more
thing to do I have to over like one more
maths sack to study for um mm-hmm
before like the end of the term which is
on in like a week so yeah I will see you
guys later bye